legal illegal scheißegal ich will ins
drogengeschäft einsteigen hier in
neumünster wird medizinisches cannabis
angebaut also richtig gutes zu fliehen
die ohren weg wir sind hier im
maschinenraum also wir haben die
pflanzen und die technik getrennt das
heißt techniker und gärtner begegnen
sich nie die pflanzen bleiben nur in
ihrer welt
eine parallelwelt die man nur unter
höchsten sicherheitsvorkehrungen
betreten darf aber eine geile neue welt
das ist tatsächlich historisch gesehen
die erste generation der wir hier in
staatlicher lizenz anbauen und dann
nehme ich mir einen als erinnerung mit
das ist darf ich leider nicht die
erinnerungen gaben im geiste sie haben
ja sich hat er in bild ich jetzt
vorstellungsvermögen ja sie müssen wir
einen durchziehen mal runterkommen ein
bisschen entspannen
[Musik]
gott ist das schön welche diagnose
brauche ich wohl damit dass hier noch
als eigenbedarf durchgeht
ich will rain in ihr business ich sage
wie es ist was muss ich tun
ich will hier jetzt anfangen also wir
suchen immer noch in gärtnerei direkt
gärtnerei bereich da bräuchten sie erst
mal ein ordentliches führungszeugnisse
was sind das denn für leute die sich
hier bei ihnen bewerben
also wir waren überrascht über die
vielfältigkeit der bewerbung und leider
waren viele bewerbungen dabei die
dachten dass erfahrung im anbau hier
vorteil ich wäre aber die wissen doch
wie es geht
das sind doch keine amateure jaja
medizinisch schön und gut aber kann man
den stoff nicht einfach komplett
legalisieren was sind die vorteile einer
liberaleren drogenpolitik
wie sorgen sie bessere qualität also ich
muss mir nur vorstellen meine kinder
müssen auf dem schwarzmarkt kaufen nicht
irgendwelche drogen die völlig
verunreinigt sind es viel besser wenn
sie saubere und ordentliche drogen in
der apotheke beziehen
wir würden geld einnehmen als start und
wir würden die polizeit lasten in berlin
macht eine anzeige wegen cannabis besitz
eine stunde arbeit ein drittel der
anzeigen werden wieder fallen gelassen
das heißt 6000 stunden unnötige
polizeiarbeit kann man die nicht
sinnvoller nutzen zum beispiel mit candy
crash die bekämpfung der
drogenkriminalität und des drogenkonsums
ist sinnvoll auch bei cannabis wir sehen
ganz oft auch die folgen die dahin
stehen können wo junge menschen die
einmal probieren wollten beendet sind
und von daher ist die arbeit schon sehr
sind neben mir steht der mofas hat von
der partei die linke
sie können die maske ruhig ausziehen
weil wir stehen jetzt weit genug
auseinander
na klar mach ich was mich interessiert
sind sie pro oder contra cannabis pro
cannabis in kanada wurde ja cannabis
legalisieren interessanterweise ist die
einzige gruppe bei der man feststellen
kann dass mehr konsumiert wird männer ab
das sind wahrscheinlich männer die ihr
leben lang gesoffen haben und jetzt
feststellen
cannabis irgendwie angenehmer ich habe
nicht so viele probleme wie mit alkohol
günther jauch hat ja ein weingut und der
trinkt ja gern mal was von seinem wein
wie sieht das bei ihnen
also ich hab kein weingut und trinkt
trotzdem gerne was sie will sie wissen
schon worauf die frage abzielt sie sind
richtig spielverderber wissen wir das ja
das ist das wird man wenn man als
staatlich lizensierter drogenanbau eben
arbeitet dann muss man sich an die
regeln halten sonst ist man am nächsten
tag heraus finden sich nicht unheimlich
dass es da eine politische schnittmenge
gibt zwischen fdp grünen und linken habe
kein problem mit aber in einem punkt
unterscheiden wir wollen darauf dass
kanada exportiert werden die sind ja für
cannabis made in germany als
verkaufsschlager
da machen die linke nicht mit dass für
die böse profit wenn ich kein problem
wird gewinnen also das ist ja
unterschied aber dieser eine punkt wenn
mal einer meinung das wird kein problem
8 von diesen kammern gibt es ja es ist
technisch wahnsinnig aufwendig ich habe
ein kumpel das ist der ecke der hat
einen schrank da ist ein großes led
licht und das funktioniert auch also das
kann man auch rauchen sagt der ecke und
den ecke kenne ich jetzt nicht und auch
nicht was er so im gesetzlichen rahmen
dafür erlaubnisse hat gar keine und ecki
nimmt das nicht so nicht so genau heikki
und ich haben ja auch versprochen ich
bringe mal was mit ihr das man damals im
check macht und mal guckt das kann ich
leider nicht genehmigen da müssten wir
sie hier bei der polizei den stelle
schon helden da ist ecke gemeldet wir
sind jetzt auch die schwierigen bereich
für mich jeden fall ja sie wissen ja
dass polizist hat die strafverfolgung 2
bei ihren ersten äußerung könnte ich von
einem anfangsverdacht aus verändert sich
das interview in einer vernehmung ja
vielleicht brechen wir ab jetzt wäre
eine möglichkeit an so sie einen anwalt
hinzuziehen
jan ist ein anwalt hier nervt es sie
eigentlich dass cannabis immer noch mit
diesen alten klischees behaftet ist
das nimmt dieser ganzen diskussion
einfach die wissenschaftliche grundlage
und ich würde mir wirklich freuen wenn
wir nicht ideologisch sondern
wissenschaftlich diskutieren und
wirklich die vorteile der pflanze auch
mehr in den vordergrund rücken
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken märz gut los los du
scheiße fährt